human beings are formed like molten
glass
and over the next nine years we can
shape that human being into
any thing we decide you can do it for
good you can do it for evil and that's
where and that's because of the meaning
making machine in our head
and how we perceive meaning and then
once we see meaning we decide that that
is real
our beliefs become a reality i believe
that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we
really want and i want to help give you
the tools
to make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense today on the show
is a gentleman by the name of vishen la
kyani he is all about consciousness
engineering which you'll hear about
he has a learning platform called mind
valley
which is rooted in forgiveness he's bet
harvard university that he can create a
better system online for college
engineering
he started a workout program called 10x
he's got a new book coming out called
the six phase
meditation i mean this guy this guy is
busy
he also has a festival called a-fest
that i've you'll see here at the
beginning i asked to be invited to
which is all about going to a beautiful
location and
learning about uh really fascinating
topics about existence and technology
and all kinds of things
um and man i'm gonna say look we get
into it uh we don't necessarily agree on
everything but i think that the most
healthy thing that we can do
is listen to each other and have healthy
conversations
uh and and be open-minded to uh
what a new thought looks like and what
old thoughts look like and what systems
need to go and what
new ones need to come you're gonna hear
some crazy stuff you know look the human
experience is
pretty interesting and uh so was this
interview
i'm really wondering how i can get
invited to a-fest
danica you come on all you got to do is
let me know
um like going to some exotic location
and learning about
consciousness and manifesting and all
kinds of
superhuman tricks i'm like yeah that's
very much up my alley
you would love a-fest you'd be it's like
your kind of people where are you
where are you right now i'm in arizona i
live in scottsdale nice
nice yeah you're somewhere very far away
um i'm in estonia i live here now
wow why it's it's south of finland
yeah so it's it's about -10 outside my
apartment is like a log cabin
but i love it i love being here it's
this beautiful medieval city walking
outside it's like being in disneyland
it's uh this is a thousand year old
medieval city
400 000 people and it's one of the most
beautiful little spots on the planet
what made you choose estonia
i was married to an estonian for a while
and so i have two little estonian
children
and we wanted them to grow up in europe
where they could learn
their mother tongue and so they go to
school here ah
huh how old are they seven and thirteen
oh man what are they into
um well right now virtual reality
computer games star wars
and the marvel superhero universe they
are like
they're like ordinary american kids
anywhere
so that's really that's really cool i i
think it's so fascinating with kids they
all have such their
own individual personalities and they
come through at such a young age you
know you can tell if people are
kids are artistic or if they're athletic
or
you know interested in technology um so
it's imaginable i guess that they'd be
playing
dealing with a little bit of technology
because i feel like
for you know diving in and learning more
about you
and and and you have so much going on
but
a lot of it has to do with
how do i it's like looking at yourself
like a computer bingo you you hit the
nail
right in the head in my first book i
wrote about a concept called
consciousness engineering
and it's the idea that we can approach
ourselves the way one programs are
computed now my background
is electrical engineering and computer
science i graduated from the university
of michigan
same same university as larry page uh
lots of
great engineering alumni but at a
certain point
i got fed up of silicon valley like
it it was just miserable i was in
silicon valley when the dot-com bubble
burst
and i lost everything i lost the funding
for my startup
i i had no insurance and i wrecked my
car
and in the end i basically couldn't
afford rent i was i was sleeping on a
couch trying to figure things out
sending my resume out to everyone anyone
who would accept me on craigslist
now finally um i found a job
in um technology sales to lawyers
so i had to pick up the phone every day
and and interrupt
a texan lawyer and pitch him on a
software
right and if you know anything about
lawyers
and texan lawyers they hate being
interrupted in the middle of a busy day
by some freaking telemarketer with back
then i had a more malaysian accent
so i would hear more [ __ ] off kids
than i ever expected and i guess one day
after the 13th lawyer told me to f off
i fell into a depression and i started
questioning the meaning of life
so i got on google and i started
searching for hope and i found i can't
remember what i put in google maybe it
was like
help me not make my life suck so bad
right
google had just come out we didn't
really know what it was capable of
but i discovered something called the
silva method
now the silva method turns out is a
meditation
program that started in laredo texas
by a by a texas mexican
immigrant by the name of jose silva it
became massively popular
jose silva sold like something like 12
million books it was one of america's
first
personal growth protocol jose silva had
died in 1999 and this was 2002
but the ideas gripped me i took a
seminar on the silver method
and it transformed my life now the
interesting thing was
this was a form of meditation that was
unlike meditation from the east i grew
up in an indian
family i was used to eastern style
meditation
silver method it was about it was
meditation to pursue your goals you did
not clear your mind
rather you you grappled with whatever
thought whatever
vision whatever passion whatever
whatever goal you wanted to reach
with intensity and you applied your mind
to get there
but at the same time there was a
peacefulness about it
you learn how to listen to your still
inner voice you learn how to tap into
your intuition
and all the while i'm thinking what the
[ __ ] this is tex max meditation
i was expecting the taco bell of
meditation it was more like chipotle it
was just absolutely delicious
and so i go back i go and literally it
was started by
by jose silva who lived between nobel
laureato and laredo
on a border town so i go back to san
francisco with my
my sales job and in one week i double my
sales
one month later i double it again one
month later i double it again
for in four months i'm promoted three
times they make me vice president of
sales and at 26 years old
i'm sent to new york to lead the
company's new york office and that
is how my passion for the human mind
because i learned
none of that in school yeah with silva i
learned
intuition i learned creative
visualization i learned how to set and
pursue goals with
this level of mental faculty that almost
seemed as if
reality would bend in your favor and
that's how i started my work and how i
started mindvalley
which is why i'm asking you about this
first because in my opinion
if you can't accept that you can
work with neuroplasticity and
reprogram yourself then you know
telling yourself you're enough or um
setting goal like it doesn't matter you
have to really like get into the belief
process and you have to start
understanding
the power of the mind and
so it's so i mean i i get super into
this
aspect because i i'm all about
manifesting i'm all about the
nature of reality which includes what
are we
really so right i hear all this stuff
i'm actually like maybe this is like
jumping too far but like what are we
if we're able to reprogram like that
are we like elon musk says are we just a
simulation
like have you do you have an opinion on
that
or a feeling or are we actually
human so i remember i remember in 2017
um i was on the board of the xprize
foundation right so the xprize
foundation that's the uh
that's the foundation that elon musk
just donated a hundred million dollars
to
for the carbon capture x xprize so
um i was on the board for that
foundation and peter diamandis the
founder took us in the tour
of all the top virtual reality and ai
laboratories in california and there was
this one particular moment where they
assembled
six experts in ai and
and and virtual reality so this was
2017.
these six experts were on stage and
diamandis asked them
given where you see ai is going and how
powerful and amazing ai is
and given that given the the sheer
number of planets that we now know exist
in the universe and how massive the
universe is
do you think we are living in a
simulation created by an alien species
and how many of those six do you think
agreed with the simulation hypothesis
i think all of them five out of six
right five out of six and these were
america's top ai and vr
specialists they knew how powerful vr
was about to become they knew how
powerful ai
is about to become just just in our
lifetime in our lifetime they also know
that given what we know about the
universe
you know a species like us may be around
for another million years
two million maybe where are we going to
be then right
i mean look what happens in 10 years
look what happens in 100 years
what's going to happen in a million i
mean it's like it's unfathomable we
don't even
like i interviewed neil degrasse tyson
and a while back and
he the question that plagued him the
most is that he won't know the right
question to even ask
right right and so it is highly probable
that we are living in some sort of
simulation
um and if so i want to figure out
how to hack it right well even if we are
in a simulation okay
hang on let's do you believe that there
is
an omnipresent consciousness
that we all are embodying if we're in
simulation
yes there is enough evidence that shows
that our brains
are able to source information from
outside
physical matter for example newark
college of engineering
did a study uh it was by professor john
mihalosky
he wrote a book on it called executive
esp and
he wanted to test a really simple
hypothesis okay everyone has seen
ghostbusters right
so there's this scene um right at the
start of ghostbusters
where bill murray is is holding up these
cards and he's
he's doing a study in a basement of a
university he's holding up these cards
and the woman on the opposite end
has to guess the picture on the card now
of course being bill murray he's taking
it as a joke he's trying to hit on the
woman but these are called xena counts
and studies like in duke university in
in
um newark college of engineering they
use zener cards to test
intuition so mihalaski tested this on
ceos and he found that there was a
direct correlation
ceos who were who were guessing a birth
chance there are five cards chance would
be 20
some ceos were guessing 25 28 right
if they were guessing above chance it
correlated with
those ceos also being better ceos in
terms of profitability increase in the
company
but he also found another curious
phenomenon there were ceos
who were guessing against chance that
means odds say they should be
wrong 80 of the time but they were wrong
ninety percent of the time and it was as
if they were they were self sabotaging
each
themselves and it turned out these ceos
they were having the most horrible
profit uh
growth in their company they were
showing themselves
yeah so it turns out that that this
study and the book is called executive
esp suggests that
we can actually tap into something to
make better decisions to move us forward
but we can also do the opposite we can
second guess ourselves
and make bad decisions and it reflects
in how we are performing at work
which is what happened to you when you
after you did that meditation class is
that you started tapping into your
natural intuition
right i would knew i would know which
lawyer to call
that would have a higher probability of
me closing the lawyer
now here's here's how it worked so today
today there's a huge amount of research
in altered states of consciousness
we know there's the alpha state there's
the data state that's the delta state
silva does a programming technique to
teach you
how to instantly slow down your brain
waves and go into what is called an
alpha state of consciousness
now you can train yourself to do that
now in the silver method he uses
hypnotic programming and meditation
to induce it in you so that whenever you
join your three fingers together like
this
instantly you slow down your brain waves
now it doesn't work for you but it works
for me if i was hooked up to an eeg
machine an electroencephalograph
if i did this my brainwave states would
slow down it's a trigger it's like when
a hypnotist says when i snap my fingers
you will crack like a duck
right it's a trigger but it stays with
you now
when you go into the alpha level of mind
you're able to tap into
intuition intuition is magnified so what
i learned now back then
um the way we sold to lawyers in texas
we would go to the san francisco public
library check out the yellow pages
i'd be assigned a territory like san
antonio and i'd have to call every
lawyer from a to z
put an x if he didn't say if he said no
put an effort he told me to [ __ ] off you
know whatever
now what i learned is that i could join
my fingers together like this
go into this meditative stance not even
look at the yellow pages just
run my finger down and feel an impulse
and at a certain point i'd feel this
impulse it felt like a burst of joy
or something like like like an aha and i
would open my eyes see where my finger
was and call that lawyer
and overnight i double my sales
overnight now
if you are in sales and you're a
professional you track everything
you know your closing rate you know the
number of assistants you have to call
you know the the number of calls that
last beyond 20 minutes that number of
people
who asked to hand me hand you a brochure
i had all of that data
my performance doubled overnight in one
week i double my sales
we're using that technique and
my frustration is why aren't most people
talking about intuition
so that's how i got interested in this
entire field
i agree i mean i i i don't know
where along the way like do you feel
that we
in a long time ago used to
be more in tune with our intuition and
like i look back at even like um you
know
biblical stories or religious stories
and they're like and then the voice of
god
and then it came to me in a dream and
then there was a angel
and i'm like why can't we just replace
that with consciousness
and like higher self and you know like
we absolutely can so there so again i i
quote a lot of studies and a lot of
signs because i know that i'm walking a
fine line here
and i respect your audience i love your
line by the way thank you
i wanna i wanna i wanna share the sign
so there's a a paper
called perceptual diversity and it says
and it was published in 1973 by a
scientist called boginio
now what boganyon found is that 90
of all the indigenous cultures in the
world in 1973
had some form of practice that involved
altered states
going into alpha going into theta the
chinese had kung fu
um the japanese had um had
art like aikido buddhist meditation the
hindus had
kriya practices um christian monks had
their practices muslim sufis had their
practices
but as the world progressed a lot of
these
were sidelined in favor of the rational
mind
now the great american philosopher ken
wilbur talks about
how the age of rationality caused people
to look at religion and go oh that is
[ __ ]
but then because of how how and and
and they had a right to do that because
religion did contain a lot of bs
but the rational mind when it moved
the rational mind moved beyond religion
started also labeling
what is called transrational
spirituality
bs as well so there are two types of
spirituality that's pre-rational
which is often associated with religion
the burning bush
you are born a sinner um pray to lord
ganesha
and your dreams will come true that's
pre-rational spirituality that
spirituality before
the rational age there might be some
truth in it but there's also a lot of
dogma a lot of bs a lot of
um manipulation by religious entities
then the rational age came with the
renaissance the rational age came with
the industrial age
and people rebelled against religion
especially in the united states
but now that rebellion also moved
towards what is called
trans-rational spirituality
trans-rational spirituality
is explorations about it states through
meditation
it's high ayahuasca and plant medicine
it's an acceptance of intuition
it's tantra energy during um
during intimacy if so we need
to dance a fine line we need to embrace
the age of rationality
and yes question religion there's so
much crap in religion
but do but also be open to
to transrational spirituality and that's
what we're talking about here
so bogino said that there is a loss
of acceptance for altered states
and she she said that just like we are
losing
ethnic diversity right as everyone is
exposed to american cable television
we are losing what is called perceptual
diversity we are learning
and starting to believe that the only
way to see is through our eyes
yeah but there's more there's astral
projection there's lucid dreaming
there's altered states of consciousness
that's tapping into the beyond there's
the samadhi experience that's waking up
and that perceptual diversity is what we
now
need to go back into and start exploring
yeah well i mean there's a lot of
information on
uh in history using those modalities
especially like
plant medicine being a very normal thing
and so you know to like thin the veil
between
you know what we have conditioned
ourselves to believe is real
and what's beyond that do you have you
done any of that stuff
oh my god i have done everything
i um i i created my own meditation
practice called the six faith it's
actually used by a lot of american
sports stars uh it's been written about
in the new york times billboard magazine
it's free online so just just google it
um the six-based meditation
and also look that's gonna be a book too
right it's gonna be it's gonna be my new
book yeah yeah i just signed a deal with
penguin random house
i'm also a big proponent of ayahuasca i
think everyone should experience it at
least
once i try to do it every five years and
i use ayahuasca to get the most
incredible
business ideas i believe any ceo
who is not using plant medicine is at a
competitive disadvantage today
yeah what um what uh tell me a business
idea that came from an ayahuasca
ceremony right so so uh if you're part
of mindvalley you know that there's this
thing called mindvalley membership which
is where all our transformation programs
are open to you
and there's an app and we've now started
creating our own private social network
i i was i did ayahuasca uh i can't say
when
i sorry i can't say when and i can't say
when it was
jen jan last year so jan 2020. i cannot
say
where because i may or may not have done
it in a place where it was legal
um so let's avoid that question but what
happened when i did ayahuasca is i went
into a seven minute conversation with
god knows what and i got screen by
screen
by screen the ux the function
the the the specific the specifics of
the app
uh to to build to foster community in my
business
and so we went all out and we started
building it and it's taking off like
crazy
but what amazed me is how specific the
nuances were
the pandemic hadn't hit yet but this was
that what
what i gained from ayahuasca is that i
need to find an engineer a way to bring
my students together outside real world
seminars
and this was two months before the
pandemic hit and now that app is a
godsend yeah thank god because
all our real world seminars are
cancelled but it got weirder
when i was in this plant medicine thing
and i and i i saw the front screen of
the app
and you know what many apps have a
facebook login yeah
so there was this thing on the front
screen that that with an x over facebook
and i and so i saw that vision the whole
ux of the app and the vision and i asked
this this force what does that mean why
is there an
x over facebook and it said facebook
you shouldn't be trusting facebook with
your user data
do not work with facebook so i thought
okay that that's kind of crazy because
um we know facebook is so dominant
now look at what is happening next week
with apple's new ios update
they are banning facebook data gathering
i'm sure you you read the news apple and
facebook has gone to war
tim cook has basically said that he will
no longer support
and he completely slammed facebook
facebook stock price has gone down
because of facebook's privacy violations
right exactly what my ayahuasca vision
told me one year before
and um and so yeah in this app we
actually made a we actually set a rule
with my engineers
we set a philosophy called don't suck
like zuck
and it simply meant adopt the most
the most safe um eu standard gdpr
uh uh privacy policies and do not
manipulate
user data or sell advertising so the the
visions for ayahuasca
gave me step by step by step
you know in a bizarre way things i
needed to do for my business and this is
why i say
if you're a ceo and you're not using
plant medicine or other modalities to
tap into altered states you are at a
competitive disadvantage
now now there are four modalities you
want to look at based on danielle
goldman and his book alter traits
we talked about for plant medicine we
talked about meditation
the other two are neuro training and
breath work
neuro training would be more of the
consciousness engineering right
neuro training though consciousness
engineering is just a way of looking at
the world oh right it's a philosophy of
life
neurotrainings where is where you strap
your brain
to um advanced biofeedback machines
and you train your brain to dip into
other realities so you are so typically
in euro training what they look at
are two things if you study the brain
waves of zen roshi monks
you find that there's a certain elegance
to it
they have a left right brain hemisphere
coherence that means the waves are
balanced
okay and then they have really high
alpha amplitude
now you can train this there are
facilities popping up around the world
that actually
train people two that i've studied at is
the biocybernaut institute in canada
and 40 years of zen by dave asprey in
seattle it's expensive it's 15 000
five days i have no affiliation with
either and there are other facilities
popping around the world but what they
say they do
is that they map into your br they train
your brain to generate the same waves
as monks who have spent years in
meditation
now i have done it and i can vouch for
it because i've noticed
a massive difference in how i showed up
in the world after five days
in those um um indoor facilities
okay incredible that's a little bit
harder to access that so like
of the four things probably the most
difficult is finding stuff finding
somewhere where you can
yeah it's the most difficult and the
most expensive right like ayahuasca uh
you still gotta travel it may still take
three or four days
neuro training is 15 grand it's
expensive right i'm sure it'll get
cheaper i'm sure it'll get cheaper
as the years progress and then breath
work
which i mean you can literally get
yourself
high off of breath work exactly now the
issue with breathwork is is that
breathwood brings up a lot of trauma it
brings up a lot of [ __ ] that you gotta
face and heal
but breath work is some it's sometimes
harder in breath work
to actually um source ideas
so i i might use breath work to
to to face myself to work on my
shadows we all have shadows we all have
some some
bs belief or some dark aspect of our
soul that we need to face brett work is
great for that
in terms of sourcing ideas i prefer um
plant medicine or meditation yeah well
they
i mean to get into that i feel that in
an aspect of some of the things i do and
in like a somatic sort of healing way
where
i've felt for myself when i use breath
um
i'm like i'm dislodging stuck energy in
my body to process it and then
my mind turns into a movie and i
actually start to see something
happening
of a process trauma that's coming
through or i just start crying
i mean so absolutely and these are these
are such foreign concepts for most
people but they're
so accessible and i i mean you can
practice them literally in your living
room
and um the reason why i go into all this
with you because is because i feel like
understanding reality helps you know how
to use it
exactly exactly understanding reality
helps you know how to use it
i love that quote that's why i seek
truth is because
in that truth is like how a direction of
how i should live my life
and so when i understand that my mind
which this is a fascinating thing that
so few people
really have an understanding for and
that's the the
and i'm and i'm and i think it has to do
from my understanding
with your brain wave states but you are
you are programmed from
something like the last trimester with
you in the womb
for the until the first six or seven
years of your life is that correct
that's your subconscious program at a
vast level
yeah some people say all the way up to
uh all the way up to age nine
i think i don't think anybody knows the
exact number but for sure there's a ton
of subconscious programming
world views beliefs that go into our
mind
as we are growing up and that has to do
with from what i understand the brain
waves your brain waves are in
theta i believe most of the time which
is sort of that slightly hypnotic state
which allows you to put things into the
system
which is exactly that's why you meditate
while you do those other practices
because you
your brainwave states and a lot like
programming yes you can you can
reprogram at the alpha level that's what
jose silva found in his research
now why is it that we can program
children
right why is it that children it's
because children children have a meaning
making machine in their head
it is actually evolutionary hard wired
in us
to generate meaning human beings
build and survive we've built
civilization based on stories
and so stories stories allow us
to navigate a highly complex world yuan
hariri
the famous israeli professor who wrote
the book sapience
has a beautiful quote he said every
other
animal is born fully formed a perfect
replica a smaller but replica
of the older animal but not the human
being
the human being is born like molten
glass
and this is why we can shape a human
being to be a war monger or a pacifist
a christian or a buddhist
and that's a beautiful thing about that
quote human beings are formed like
molten glass
and over the next nine years we can
shake that human being into
any thing we decide you can do it for
good you can do it for evil
and that's where and that's because of
the meaning making machine in our head
and how we perceive meaning and then
once we see meaning
we decide that that is once we we
generate meaning
we decide that that is real our beliefs
become a reality
and we fail to see anything else outside
what we believe to be true
yeah i feel like i could get into a
whole
spiral about trauma
childhood but basically the
understanding is is that
they hold you back so it's important to
go through these modalities
so that you can start to unlock the
emotions
the patterns the things that keep
showing up in your life
that you because you know i love the
like you know
your issues your patterns come knocking
at the door and it breaks it down and
then it you know ravishes your house and
then finally it's got to burn it down
right i like that and so it's so
important to get
through these things so that we can
achieve something that we really want
and so
forget that you have so there's so much
more to ask you about than go on a
rampage about that but
i think that then what comes into um a
practice that i found beautiful
in in learning more is means goals and
ends goals
i think that for me this yes reprogram
your mind
learn new belief systems but then
understand why like why are you doing
what you're doing because
uh it's like if somebody has a goal to
lose weight and then they do well then
what
or if somebody has a goal to make money
well you're gonna do it and then what
and so
how do you align yourself with a life
that will uh have a never-ending purpose
to keep you fulfilled right
so so a means goal is a means to an end
an end goal is what really lights us up
right so end goals are what we should be
pursuing
but our upbringing our parents our
religion our society
get us to chase mean skull a classic
example in america
do you know anyone who became a lawyer
sure
right i have so many friends from the
university of michigan who went into law
school
funny thing a lot of them went into law
school because they saw law as a
glamorous
profession um i remember like growing up
in the 90s there was allie mcbeal there
was
l.a law there were all of these hit
television shows that glorified lawyers
but it turns out that if you're a lawyer
in america you have a 50
chance of suffering from depression 50
why would anybody want to go into a
career where there's a 50
chance of suffering from depression now
it's not just in the u.s lawyers in
australia i just read in a study
also a 50 chance now the reason is is
programming
we are programmed to believe in american
society it's programmed to believe that
being a lawyer is glamorous america has
five percent of the world population 70
percent of
the world's lawyers and half of them
clinically depressed yet we keep
churning out law graduates now why
it's because of the end goal means goal
crap
now i had a friend i had several friends
actually who became lawyers and
i remember several almost all of them
quit law at this point
they quit law and they became a coach
and they quit law and they became a
world traveler
a writer but why did they go into law
it's because they were chasing a mean
school not an
end goal i remember i had one friend
and he wanted to do he wanted to serve
the world he wanted to
help people who were poor and he thought
he's going to be this
incredible international lawyer he's
going to like fight for indigenous
groups he's going to fight against the
big corporations
his end goal was serve the poor
the means goal is where he got tripped
up he decided he had to work really hard
go in that graduate from law school and
he did he graduated from harvard
with massive debt he had to join a law
firm
which he did in washington dc that
within
three years he went into a divorce
because he was so busy
he and his wife they just didn't have
time for each other
long story short he ended up quitting
law traveling around south america
and discovering that he could do his end
goal serving the poor
without that crazy law degree he
started several businesses he helped
support um
[Music]
several poor people in south america he
volunteered for non-profits
he figured out that you could get to the
end goal without going through
the societal programming that says oh
you need to do well
in high school you need to apply to a
good university you need to do well in
your lsat you need to take student debt
and go to law school you need to join a
firm you need to work 100 hour weeks so
you become partner then
you've made it these are all means goals
we are better
served if we look at the end goal and
then figure out
how do we carve our own original path to
the end goal
so you want to identify the angles and
there are three types of end goals the
first one
is experiences so holding a newborn baby
in your arm that is an incredible
experience
serving the poor incredible experience
backpacking across the himalayas
incredible experience
being waking up every day next to the
man or woman you love
these are experiences you want to put
down in your goal list next you want to
ask yourself
to be that man or woman who has these
experiences how do i need to grow
you want to backpack across the
himalayas well firstly you probably want
to exercise your legs
you probably want to have enough passive
income so you can afford to take a year
off
you probably want to be able to maybe
speak a dialect
that is that's that's useful there like
maybe hindi or nepali
how do you want to grow and then the
final question you ask yourself is if i
had these experiences if i have grown to
be this man or woman
how do i then give back to the world and
the reason for that question is because
while
studies show that there's a difference
between happiness and fulfillment and
happiness
can come very easily you can smoke a
joint and be happy
but to be fulfilled it comes through
growth and giving
and that last question how can i give
back to the world
is where you really are engineering your
life for fulfillment
so experiences growth contribution
egc and that is an
exercise that i teach people and it
helps you go straight
to your end goals now once you have that
you are no longer a victim of the giant
human photocopy machine
you are not just a photocopy of every
other
life out there you've created your own
beautiful
work of art you've created your own
painting
of what your life is to be unique to you
well without paying attention to any of
the bs from society
there are rules and then there are rules
abroad b-r-u-l-e-s is a [ __ ] rule
a [ __ ] rule that media society
politicians
culture religion tells you you need to
follow
because apparently some view thousands
of years ago
thought it was the way right to be a
truly original human being
you need to question the rules and you
need to aim for end goals
not means goals
we are in such a time where i feel like
systems
and uh and industries
are being challenged and crumbled and
maybe my
definitely the one i am the most
passionate about
is school and
i think it's like a lot of [ __ ] i
think that it's a brule
going to college is a brule uh i didn't
go to college that's part of it right i
mean i left high school when i was 16
years old
i have a ged which is called my good
enough diploma
and i i dismissed my intelligence for a
long time because i never want to be
judged for not knowing really simple
things that maybe someone else learned
in school like
i don't know when the civil war was like
it's something i don't know
and also do i give a [ __ ] no does it
help me any day
or hurt me it's nothing it's nothing it
doesn't matter
so i get a little fired up when i think
about school i think about college but i
also think about um i also think about
the systems below it i think about
when you go to school what age you're at
what you're actually being taught the
patterns that are being instilled into
you as far as like
following orders and sitting in the same
spot and stop
using your imagination and there's a
whole world of school that very
frustrating but i definitely think that
one of them that is a real problem that
could shift and
you are going to help shift that is
college because
it puts you in this terrible loop of
you get done with school you go to
college
you go in debt or your family's going in
debt but let's just
let's just put it to you to use as an
example and all of a sudden now
you're put on this hamster wheel of i
get out of school now i have to just
take the first job that comes
because i got to pay my bills and i got
to have somewhere to live and i got to
eat
and then you don't have the opportunity
to dream and take a chance and not earn
an income because you're already in debt
you've got to pay bills
so now all of a sudden you stay in the
sucky cycle of like i'm not at a job i
really want but i have to do it and i
can't take chance
most people aren't that brave most
people are really feel very stuck
and um and i just think it's the biggest
loop i think it's like
loops you into a really sucky life most
of the time
and um i i i just i have to talk to you
about that because
to me this is like a really cool
initiative to
i tell tell i i your challenge to
harvard is fantastic
so what i what i believe my team and i
my team is around
400 people uh right now what i believe
we're going to be able to pull off
is to deliver better advantages in life
than a harvard degree
for 1 100 the price a harvard degree
today is 50 grand
so we have to deliver this for 500 a
year that's it
and that's what mindvalley is about so
we're building a platform
and it's it's it's a powerful platform
on the surface it looks like netflix for
high quality education so you have all
of these incredible teachers
teaching you the things that truly
matter from meditation to goals to
athletic performance to
to speed reading uh all of these things
that elevate your career
increase your productivity but the
underlying layers where the magic is
happening
we're using ai to not just train you and
give you the stuff that's
right for you but we are providing a
platform where
the more you input into it as you take
down your notes
as you use the platform to build your
goal list so soon you can build your
goals in the platform
the ai is able to learn about you
and then not just give you the right
content
so it's education customized to who you
want to be but also introduce you to the
right people
so we're building on the back end the
world's most advanced human to human
matching engine we are getting so close
to predicting
who you are going to fall in love with
predicting who you're going to be close
friends with
in your city predicting who you should
work who you should start a company with
a black mirror episode right now what
it is but we are using it for good not
for evil
i mean that's yes i i agree there is
just like with everything there's a
light in the dark there's a yin and yang
to everything and so
exactly like how do we just same with
social media social media can be an
absolutely destructive
piece of information for you to make you
feel like the worst human in the world
and go down rabbit holes and distract
you
or it can expand your mind the big
purpose of social media aka
facebook they say oh we're about
connecting the world but no they're not
building a true
system for connecting the world they're
building a system to suck
your your your attention so they can
sell you more [ __ ] you don't need
it's an advertising platform we're doing
the opposite we're building true
connection
you see what my theory is that the best
way for people to connect
is based on shared learning shared
transformation
think about it right like the best
you've always heard this phrase the best
people to date are people who
are constantly growing it's always about
learning
when you and when you and a friend are
learning together you're exploring
something new together
you tend to click because we have all of
this data
on what people are enjoying learning
what people's goals are what their
visions are
and everything is it says it's a
feedback loop that allows us to then
every day online value pretty soon we're
gonna predict
um who you should connect with now
here's here's how we do it it's really
cool
yeah this is released in about a year so
if you open up the mindvalley app it'll
say danica
we found that there's this guy called
greg he is
two kilometers away from you and we
recommend that you guys get together for
coffee
eighty percent chance you guys are going
to hit it off we don't say
whether it's a potential date or a
potential friend or a potential person
that you should hire for your company
you decide that but the algorithm
can predict it can predict now it gets
even better
when you and greg meet up for coffee you
click a button on your phone
and it gives both you and greg questions
to ask each other
it now becomes a game so it says danica
asked greg
about his favorite movie you have a
common favorite actor
danica asked greg about his vision for
the next 10 years of his life
there's something he's going to say that
you'll be able to help him with
that's that's freaky that's where this
is going
it's not creepy it's stunningly human
it's so how is that stunningly human
because we're connecting you based on
based on you being
human we are we are think about all the
clutter around think about the sheer
number of people that are lonely that
are
craving close connection and it's hard
not only do we have this damn pandemic
but no one is real anymore
we're building because of social media
if we are able to
cut through the clutter and and identify
that there's someone in your city that
we know
you're gonna click with and we can bring
you guys together
that's that's true human connection
okay so let's say let's like extrapolate
this out so let's say this happens
which it's going to um so this happens
and people believe in this product
people believe in this system
now you have people believing in it
which is
really really really powerful now you're
the new control system you can literally
make someone like or not like
somebody based on the fact that they
believe that's
this the they believe the information
that is a slippery slope
that's very true so here what we bring
in is human assistant ai
so what this means is this okay so so
firstly when you come to the system you
set who
you want to meet okay so you might say i
am looking to hire people into my
company
or you might say you know i have this
business idea i'm looking to find a
potential co-founder
or you might say i want to meet the
freaking love of my life
okay now what happens then is human
assisted ai works like this think of it
as an algorithm
70 of your chance of of your match
is powered by ai so they so let's say
you want to meet
a potential friend no dating no sex just
friendship uh a fellow woman whom you
think could be a really good sister a
really good friend
okay you put that in we find someone for
you we find three people
what happens then is these three people
are presented
to human um we call them human cupids
so these human cupids um they log into
the system and their job is to just
use their intuition to predict a match
remember intuition that thing we were
talking about and these human cupids are
ai
these human cupids are human real human
beings human volunteers
doing this because they get to help so
it shows danica and then it says these
three people a i predict that danica
should connect with
it flashes yes or no yes no yes no now
the human cupids are listening to their
intuition and they are bringing in
intuition to help with the match so it's
not pure ai
wow see that's the catch that i was
going to ask about is
is consciousness and frequency and so i
don't know how much you
believe in energy and frequency as well
i would imagine you do
um but but that you know when you
you have a resonance with with people
you have
resonance you have shoot i mean i
believe in past life
i believe in all of that stuff so
there's a lot of
factors that uh pull from the quantum in
a consciousness way
that can't be quantified by a robot
ah it can't be quantified by a robot but
it can with the right human assistant
a human assisted ai matching system
right this is you
back in better beginning with your
finger on the yellow pages
going did the intro exactly but it gets
better but it gets better
mobile rings that measure hot resonance
okay so now now we're gonna really
go go into a black mirror episode
everyone is going to have
a simple ring or a pendant that they
wear it uses a simple device that you
can manufacture in china for under 25
bucks that measures your heart
resonance studies from the heart met
institute
show that when two people are truly
connecting
their hearts beat in resonance now
here's where the magic happens when
you're having this cat
this coffee meeting with greg or shelly
or whoever we paired you up with
both of you are wearing rings and
without you guys even consciously being
aware
we are learning if your hearts are in
resonance
oh my god and we can decide
if we should if we should continue
introducing you to this type of match
so we learn the system thieves itself
wow that's so crazy
now so that is there
do you believe in like if the including
frequency so like
i don't wear the earbuds i don't wear
the watch i
i feel as though we have so much
emf interference wi-fi
and phones and everything like that it's
already happening but like why do i need
to stack it up is this really a concern
for the human body
from a frequency standpoint well it
depends on how you're reading hot
resonance right
there's not really a frequency being in
it typically what you're doing is you're
using a really sensitive
um type of device like a really think of
it as a really sensitive camera
that's reading the tiny differences in
coloration of your skin
and measuring and measuring your
heartbeat that's it
do you think about being chipped
i think it's a wonderful idea what all
of us are already part cyborg
look we we think we are purely human no
if we are staring at the screen all the
while we already part cyborg
the next step is simply the screen being
in a contact lens in our eye
oh this is black mirror i mean literally
black mirror
i mean that's that it literally is an
episode of black mirror where
he can record he records everything or
everybody's recording
everything that happens i have an icl
lens in my eye
what so i used to be i used to be
short-sighted so i did lasik and then 20
years later you know
my power got bad again and i couldn't do
lasik a second time because
i had short thin corneas so i did a
surgery called
icl uh it wasn't it wasn't
the fda hadn't approved it in the united
states so i did it in malaysia
uh now it's approved in the us but it
wasn't back when i did it
and i have a lens in my eye it's it's
like a contact lens that they inject
into your eye and then it unfolds it's
in my left eye and now i don't need
glasses anymore
it's been it's been 18 months what's the
difference between that
and a lens that has a computer chip that
projects
in front of me either way i'm not
completely human anymore
well what are we i
believe we are going to evolve into a
species that's part
matter part human part ai it's it's
elon musk is already doing it with his
with his brain
implants neurolink we're going to get
there sooner or later
the question is can we do it in a way
that's safe and makes us more connected
as a species
or we do or or do we do it in a really
douchy way where we're controlling human
behavior
you know like further stirring up the
desire
for mass consumerism it's really about
that now the reason why i'm so
passionate about this future
is because there's one thing that became
really evident to me
and that is if you want to be keep
people
happier if you want to generate
happiness it's not about more stuff
according to a harvard study by ed dino
there's only one thing that correlates
with happiness it's a 0.7 correlation
it's human connection the strength of
your human connection
then there's the blue zone study if you
want to live longer
one thing community the more community
you have
the longer you live then if you want to
be more productive at work
one thing being around people who light
you up
studies show that if you have a best
friend at work you are seven times more
engaged in your job
if you're in a team where everyone is
like supporting each other's positivity
quotient
that's the number one hallmark of a high
performance team it
all boils down to this connection
how can we create deep connection real
connection
between human beings our work improves
we no longer need to buy
endless stuff to feel happy our health
improves
we become a better species but now
when you connect people across language
barriers across religions across
countries
you get another advantage we create a
species
that can basically come together avoid
wars
take care of each other improve the
quality of our environment
and insidious things like nationalism
and we create a better human
society that's what i'm aiming for some
men are obsessed with colonizing mars
i want to fix planet earth yeah so you
would believe in a one world alliance
sort of program where ever
where it was a one world one world
government
i prefer the word earth federation from
star trek
well what planet are you from i feel
like
i feel like you might have an answer for
that i
i am proudly from planet earth
but i am but i consider myself a citizen
of planet earth first yeah i love this
planet i want to see it do
well and i want to see it survive and i
want to i
want us to not and i don't want my kids
growing up right in a planet wrecked by
climate change
well it's a it's a it's an it's an it's
a very interesting proving ground
for for consciousness to expand because
we come in forgetting everything and we
have free will and choice and so you
really learn the lessons
um because you don't have all the
answers and you don't have all the
information
which is fascinating it's a fascinating
dimension
um uh density to live in um so
i'm curious what you think is going on
because you talk about how important
community and that is so true the blue
zones are all about the people sitting
at the table with you
so now we have this situation going on
in the world where community has been
ripped from us we can't go see people we
can't
hug people that's the epidemic almost
more than anything is this lack of
connection and community
so i'm curious more from sort of another
angle of what the hell is really going
on
right well the good news is this it's
going to
end really soon bill gates has
bill gates is my former boss by the way
i used to work at microsoft i'm that
much of a geek
and have great respect for the man he
said by october this year things will
pretty much be back to normal
now the other good news emerged today
today was announced that one in 10
americans are now
have now received a vaccine and a
hundred million americans are going to
be vaccinated in the next 100 days
now what happens when when um you get
vaccinated
is that you stop the viral momentum of
the virus
so every time someone is vaccinated it
actually helps
other people because your odds of
carrying the virus
uh plummet significantly right so
uh it was just announced for example
that americans who
complete boat rounds of vaccination if
they are now exposed to someone with
covet they don't have to go in isolation
anymore
at least not for the first three months
till we learn more about the vaccine
but because of the incredible pace in
which americans are being vaccinated
you're going to see a plummeting in
corbit 19 cases
life is going to go back to normal
really really
really fast by october everything is
going to be fine which is why
i'm still doing an a fest in jordan in
october
and you're going to get an invite do i
have to have a vaccination to go
absolutely otherwise you wouldn't even
be allowed in the country
those rules are going to emerge the
middle east right now especially
israel they're leading the world in
vaccinations and israel has already
proven
that with that amount of vaccinations
covet cases in israel among the elderly
are plummeting like crazy so israel has
turned into a really good case study
why don't they just vaccinate the ones
that are at risk
like older because i mean here's the
deal like i took one of those little
blood test things one
time and i know everyone's gonna say um
you must have had it but i had the
antibody
and so everybody was like seeing my test
pop up and they're like oh [ __ ] you got
lines filling and i'm like yeah
yep line's filling in they're like no
that's not good and i'm like oh
and then they looked it up and it was
the antibody and look if i was sick
i was sick and one in february of 2020.
i was sick and they say that you know
when i took the test which would have
been like eight nine months later
that they that that wouldn't have been
possible
and then i learned information about
being able to produce your own
antibodies through an elevated uh blood
marker called iga
right so no i i completely get that
but my view on vaccination is this and
and we may we may disagree we may
disagree and again i'm not saying that
i'm only going to allow vaccinated
people into apes i'm just saying
likely the country of jordan and the
airlines are going to allow
are going to enforce that right i
believe vaccination is safe and i'm
actually going to be one of the first to
get vaccinated and i'm going to
be public about it because i believe
more people need to one of the problems
with vaccination
is that it is an emotional fear for
example
it's very it's highly unlikely for an
american to die from an act of terrorism
but most americans fear terrorism much
more
than lots of other things likewise
people fear shocks because of jaws they
fear terrorism because of the media they
fear vaccination
because of the anti-vaccine movement and
so people have
uh now it doesn't mean that vaccines are
always safe right
but people have but there is a fear that
is that
is that is partially due to emotion
and then there's legitimate fears and
you can measure that through data
probability and science
now because i live outside the united
states i recognize that there's no
anti-vaccine movement here in estonia so
everybody's just getting vaccinated
there's no fear
but at the same time even if the
anti-vaccine movement was correct and
there's a side effect of vaccination
i looked at the data and i feel that i'm
more happy to live
with that side effect because they
haven't found any major ones yet
then with what is called covet lung and
cobit lung is where even people
people like your age and my age we
survive covet but our lungs are
permanently wrecked because of how the
disease ravages your lungs i don't want
covet lung
and since i've seen no evidence for for
side effects from vaccination i'm going
down that path
do you believe that as biological beings
like let's face it we're not a robot we
are tissue we are human we are flesh
like in that way we're a bi we're
biological
if we're for natural in that way that
there would be
a natural solution a natural
fix as opposed to synthetic yeah not
always because viruses are also natural
right
with the way that that human science has
progressed to such a level
according to stephen cutler this will be
the last great pandemic
what's going to happen because we can
now engineer vaccines and soon
we'll be able the hard part is testing
vaccines the reason we didn't get a
vaccine soon is because
of the sure amount of rigorous testing
that had to go through to make sure
it was safe this is why i trust the
covet vaccine is safe
but in the future we'd be able to
simulate these tests on using artificial
intelligence
as soon as the next pandemic hits within
months we will have a vaccine
simulating the human biology using ai
that that according that is according to
kotler now here's the other thing that's
really interesting
most americans who fear vaccines don't
realize that every single day
you're already killing yourself with the
american diet
it's not the vaccines we should fear and
rebel against it's freaking coca-cola
and mcdonald's
do you know you can identify american
blood because american blood
actually you can see high fructose corn
syrup particles of high fructose corn
syrup under a microscope
like the american diet is horrendous and
this is why americans live
so much several years less two years
less
than the average european than the
average european counterpart
that is the real that is the real fear
that i think we need to be concerned
about not vaccinations i agree
you are you promote daily wellness and
i'm a i would too
like i would say to you know i i i would
say that
i am my own natural immunity every day i
wake up
i sit i sit quietly and meditate i
educate myself through information like
i love doing a podcast because honestly
it just gives me a reason to deep dive
into someone and learn more information
i was already doing it anyway
um i take cold showers i work out
i think positively i don't perpetuate my
mind with the news and things that are
not affecting my life on a daily basis
like i keep my
mind clear i stay positive i stay in
high frequency energies
and so i take i look at wellness and i
look at it like just like you said like
i look at it from a
i participate in it and every day in
every way and especially with food
i mean i i love taking care of myself
that way to the point where people are
like well you should loosen up i'm like
yeah well i like to feel good so
thank you for all the work you're doing
it's really really
really amazing and i'm excited about uh
i'm excited about uh
all the things you have going on and
maybe someday a-fest
yes but i so enjoyed this podcast
interview
you are awesome and you ask the best
questions i love the way this flows
yeah you're welcome thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button